[Musique]
comment s'y prend en 1967 un champion
cycliste pour escalader un col de haute
montagne raymond poulidor le plus doué
des coureurs français actuel pour ce
genre d'exercice va l'expliquer à sa
façon en grimpant le col du tourmalet
c'est encore le sommet oui
on aperçoit encore les derniers toit de
sainte-marie-de-campan dans la vallée le
pourcentage de la montée n'est pas trop
accentuer et raymond poulidor encore la
force de plaisanter mais jamais je
arrivé un an c'est bientôt fini
quelques kilomètres cette fois c'est
parti et je crois en effet c'est parti
et une fois de plus vraiment polydor va
connaître la vraie solitude d'un coureur
dans la montagne et le bar le plus dur
là c'est le plus dur
dos qui nommait
ah oui
pourquoi est ce que tu fais dans la
danseuse dans le vent
pour
retrouver le rythme plus puisque
quelques fois sur scène à mâlain normal
ou reste
oh
général qu'est ce que tu regardes la
roue devant la sienne ou celle du gabon
cercueil du la demande puisque on
regarde pas devant puisque si on regarde
devant moi que ça finit plus alors on a
déjà mal aux gens mais c'est fini
quelquefois les dix derniers kilomètres
on a plus la route on a plus clair or
c'est là c'est difficile
évidemment il y en a toujours qui sont
plus forts que d'autres débouche thème
sa toile et quand ça débouche lui
préfère que ce soit régulier non j'aime
bien quand ça débouche
mais pour ça il faut que faut que la
course était dure avant sinon cela
bordel au col que le peloton a roulé pas
trop vite ça fait mal après pour
attaquer le contre
en souffrir un peu puisque tout à
l'heure ne sera pas du gâteau
ce que tu entends les spectateurs
candidature pelle dans un col défend les
intérêts dans le brouillard dans les
nuages ou mais sans courage quand même
ça fait du bien même ceux qui crient
fini en sarre s'encourage
tourmalet cela colle du rhin l'un des
plus durs oui contre lui pourquoi les
pyrénées je les trouve plus dur que les
halles je sais pas pourquoi
si la galerie c'est là le plus dur ou là
et on croit que c'est pas dur
c'est pour ça que quelquefois même si on
a mal aux jambes ici qu'on a le coup de
barre c'est pari puisque c'est la route
qui rend pas celle des endroits le plus
dur si droit celle avantage
si on connaît le passage on va se plaît
et c'est pour tout le monde pareil
l'ours quelquefois c'est une histoire de
courage
le premier qui attaquent le bon on
hésite à y aller on a mal aux jeunes
quand on a mal aux jambes vous bluffez
alors il faut bluffé où il faut vous
faire voir koné faut attaquer c'est
quand on a mal aux hommes qu'il faut
attaquer les poids mais à la manger on
n'est pas loin du sommet n'est que de 5
km et on a soif alors il faut continuer
font durer la soif
ces mauvaises boire mon venant il faut
voir mais il faut savoir se retenir
on voit les bien fraîche tendu par les
spectateurs ça fait envie alors on se
donne le moral on dit jean boire et de à
table au lieu d'une
je me rattrape les trois firmes être
encore 3 km
oh
tu es capable de changer de braquet là
juste à la fin oui faut changer puisque
autrement s'asphyxie d'être le
brouillard indécente mieux montrer que
le brouillard que descendre jusqu'à mon
teint on voit pas si reste beaucoup à
faire
on voit pas les virages ni les gens qui
semblent être à plusieurs kilomètres
alors on dit peut-être le prochain
virage c'est léo
ce rapport aux 10 km sait pas où il est
il ya 49 minutes que tu m'entends
où je vire h terry c'est reparti
respirant
c'est plus de cela seulement tu as
parfois simplement que leur température
ou frais mais on n'a pas franchement 8
se rouler dans la neige mais le neige
elle attire ces gens qui passent à boire
on a soit n'ont pas la force de
démarcher les guides
son père le contact c'est fini vous
restez encore ce sens mais c'est fini on
ces derniers se soumettre terrible
heureusement des grimpeurs ou là je vais
exploser
on est dans le brouillard
le coureur au sens propre c'est ainsi et
à l'autre aussi
hu
ça y est allé quelques virages
ces jus ou
c'est pas le rôle
j'ai fini c'est fini
17 km 54 min
[Musique]